Film Courage: Well, Joe you’ve covered so
many niches from [the rock band] Metallica
in therapy, the [Arkansas] West Memphis 3,
[author/coach] Tony Robbins, [Boston ] Whitey
B., at this stage of your career how do you
know when you want to invest time and money
into a story?
What is it about a story where you say “Okay,
this is something I want to commit several
years and maybe even a lifetime to dealing
with?”
Joe: You know, I’ve been lucky enough to
cover a wide range of material and to make
quite a few films.
Somehow they keep letting me do it.
And the strange thing is that sometimes instead
of me choosing the subject, the subject kind
of chooses me at a period if my life where
I feel like there is something I need to learn.
For Tony Robbins [I AM NOT YOUR GURU] , I
was open to that kind of thinking for the
first time in my life and it’s a very positive
film because Tony had a very positive impact
on my life and I wanted to share that with
other people.
You know, some people looked at that film
and were waiting for the third-act-shoe-to-
drop where I ripped him to shreds and show
why what he’s doing is a bad thing, but
that wasn’t my intention.
With Metallica, there was a whole other set
of reasons in my life why that film came to
me.
So when I look back (in some ways and a lot
of the times) the subject that I need to learn
about at that moment seems to be my guiding
principle (as odd as that sounds) but it’s
not just a passive thing either.
Obviously I choose the films that I want to
make and generally I look for opportunities
where by focusing on the plight of a particular
individual it shines a light on a larger aspect
of the human condition.
And I think film is an incredible medium for
social change.
I mean I’ve had the good fortune of where
much of my work has had a direct impact on
a case or a situation.
And so I just finished a couple of recent
television series, one for Spike.
It’s called ‘Gone, The Forgotten Women
of Ohio,‘ where the mothers of these missing
women were feeling like nobody cared about
their situation, nobody cared about solving
this situation against these women because
they were judged by society.
And I felt like look, everyone deserves justice
regardless of your lifestyle and so I looked
into that case and was compelled to try and
help and provide some answers and I felt I
could actually make a difference.
Some stories are presented to me where I feel
like I can’t get the access or whatever.
But you know, it’s a strange group of criteria
that make me feel like this is the right thing.
And then at the most basic level, is this
a situation or are these people that I want
to spend two, two and a half years with because
that’s an arc of a film.
And even if it’s an ugly story, whether
it’s a pleasant story or an ugly story,
that’s not the deciding factor of ‘Do
I want to spend two, two and a half years?’
It’s who are these people?
Can I make an impact?
Can I be successful in my filmmaking mission?
And those are kind of the factors as to whether
or not you want to spend two and a half years
of your life doing something.